Karen Strode was born sometime in the
early 1980s this is evident based on the
fact that in 2018 Karen appears to be in
her late 30s or early 40s and this is
further backed up by the fact that she
has a teenage daughter who was born in
2000 or 2001. it's unclear who Karen's
father could have been but Karen is the
daughter of Lori Stroud
not that daughter that's Jamie Lloyd
Lori's daughter in a different timeline
think of it as an alternate reality
there's also a timeline where Lori has a
son instead of a daughter but in this
timeline it's just Karen but Karen and
Jamie do share similarities much like
Jaime she would eventually succumb to
the attacks of Michael Myers despite her
mother's excessive efforts to protect
her to learn more about Karen how Lori's
trauma was passed down to her how she's
covertly connected to Jamie Lloyd and
why the writers changed her character to
avoid controversy stick around to the
end of this video
[Music]
welcome to Horror history in today's
lesson we are taking a deeper look at
the intergenerational trauma passed down
through the Strode fans if you've seen
other Horror history episodes on
characters from the Halloween franchise
then you're likely familiar with the
Halloween Express a train map that I
came up with as an analogy to explain
the timeline each route is an alternate
timeline and each stop is a different
Halloween movie Karen appears in the
40-year timeline which follows the
original Halloween with Halloween 2018
Halloween kills and then continues on
without Karen in Halloween ends for her
first appearance in Halloween 2018
writers were initially planning to name
her Jaime as a tribute to her
counterpart from the original timeline
in a way this makes sense because both
timelines start with the same Lori
Stroud so if Lori likes that name in the
original timeline then I don't see any
reason that she wouldn't like it in this
world Jaime and Karen would have been
born around the same time in their
respective continuities only a couple
years after the timeline split in 1978.
however they probably didn't want to
confuse casual audiences into thinking
that this was Jaime so the name was
changed to Shanna Nelson and then to
Karen Nelson this was before the Karen
meme took off otherwise I'm sure they
would have gone with Shanna or something
else actually if they called her Shanna
then when they showed her old gun at the
end of Halloween 2018 the initials would
have been SS and it would have looked
like some Nazi thing maybe it's best
that they just switched it to Karen
Karen was raised and what can only be
described as army boot camp like
conditions Lori kept her daughter in a
very sheltered and strict home life and
started giving her some version of
combat training starting when Karen was
only eight years old learned how to
shoot a gun when I was eight
I learned how to fight I had nightmares
about the basement to better understand
why Lori put her own daughter through
this instead of doing normal 80s kid
stuff like riding bikes and I don't know
basically just riding bikes and riding
bikes oh did I mention riding bikes
we're gonna have to take it back to that
Infamous Halloween night in 1978.
foreign
1978 Halloween Lori started off as a
relatively happy and normal teenage girl
she was considered a good student she
would talk about crushes with her
friends and stow away her babysitting
money which probably came in handy when
she popping one out before finishing
college but on Halloween night in 1978
when all of Lori's friends are murdered
by a man in a William Shatner mask she
is left completely traumatized so much
so that once some guy in a trench coat
who she's never seen before shows up
with a gun she doesn't even question it
what's the boogeyman the murder of her
friends and subsequent attempt on her
own life understandably changed Lori
Forever at some points in her adulthood
she buys a house on a plot of land at
the edge of Haddonfield almost
completely isolated from others she
turns it into her own private bunker and
trap for Michael Myers for most of
Karen's childhood this is where she was
raised that's it
it's my childhood Lori is suffering from
post-traumatic stress disorder it's not
uncommon for parents suffering from PTSD
to pass down what is referred to as
intergenerational trauma according to a
study by psychiatric times patients with
parents suffering with PTSD often
describe damaged preoccupied parents who
are emotionally limited symptoms in
parents such as traumatic reliving
emotional numbing and dissociative
phenomena do not help a child develop a
reasonable sense of safety and
predictability in the world this would
absolutely apply to Karen as Laurie's
Trauma from the attack left her unable
to be emotionally available for Karen as
a parent even the interactions they
share as adults give a pretty clear
indication of how Lori would have
interacted with her as a child you have
no security system Karen your side
window is wide open open sometimes I
can't tell the difference between your
stupidity and your ignorance as stated
in the intro it's unclear who Karen's
father is when Laura is interviewed by a
pair of investigative journalists she
mentions that she went through two
divorces but never specifies if either
of her ex-husbands were Karen's dad my
guess is no when we see Karen's old gun
it's engraved with the letters KS she
has never been shown to be a Kansas fan
so the assumption is that this stands
for Karen Stroud if she has her mother's
last name she was probably born out of
wedlock sure maybe the father's last
name also started with s we don't now
Karen never mentions having any kind of
father figure the only men that we know
were in Lori's life at the time are
Frank Hawkins who stated that he never
made it past first base with Laurie and
Ben tramer who liked Laurie but Lori
still has a crush on him when she's old
enough to go to a bar so I'm guessing he
is not the absent father but I knew he
was sweet friend Ben Tremor either way
Karen was raised by a single mother
which is already not a good thing and
that single mother was suffering from
PTSD meaning that Karen was not afforded
with any kind of stability and had to
cope with effects of her mother's trauma
alone while Lori may have thought that
she was protecting her daughter by
teaching her to fight back against
Michael her actions would have extreme
consequences when Karen was 12 years old
the Strode household was visited by
Social Services who deemed Lori unfit to
be a mother Karen was placed into the
foster care system for the rest of her
childhood how long until Eureka custody
it didn't in foster care Karen learned
to cope with the damage that her mother
instilled by being overly optimistic and
refusing to see the world as a scary
place like Lori does there may have been
a little bit of an over correction on
the part of her new caregivers causing
her to be a little too trusting of
mankind but for the most part it seems
that they did a great job because as an
adult she seems integrated as a
productive and generally problem-free
member of society Karen eventually meets
and marries a man named Ray Nelson Rey
is the opposite of Lori in every way
where Lori is tough and over prepared
Rey is soft and it doesn't overthink
things in fact at times it seems like he
hardly thinks at all oh man I got peanut
butter on my penis at a very young age
maybe 22 at the oldest Karen becomes
pregnant with a daughter and the
addition of the newest member of the
family has an unintended side effect
Karen's mother would be coming back into
the picture
Karen and Ray Nelson gave birth to a
daughter in 2000 or 2001 and named her
Allison Karen tries to raise Allison
completely different from how Lori
raised her where Lori showed very little
interest in Karen as a person Karen goes
out of her way to be actively engaged in
Allison's life she insists on coming
Allison's induction into the National
Honor Society tells her that she's
excited to meet her boyfriend and even
though Karen avoids celebrating
Halloween due to the fact that the
anniversary of the babysitter murders
was the day that her mother was
consistently at her craziest she gives
encouragement when Allison shares that
she's planning on attending the
Halloween dance which is pretty
significant since Karen has grown to
hate Halloween so much so that she wears
a Christmas sweater on the big day
Allison's friend at one point suggests
ignoring the holiday altogether which
seems to be what Karen is going for how
are you guys I wouldn't celebrate either
I would just put up a Christmas tree
instead if I lived in Haddonfield
Michael Myers would be the least of her
worries because she'd have to answer to
me but the poor choice of attire is
further proof of Karen's refusal to
following Laurie's footsteps Lori had
tried to cope with Halloween by
preparing the a fight Karen copes by
finding something that Comforts her at
this point there are already parallels
that we can draw between Karen and Jamie
Jaime also didn't have much interest in
celebrating or dressing up for Halloween
at least At first she eventually changes
her mind so she can try to fit in with
her classmates in Halloween 2018 we see
Lori trying to prepare young Karen for
an encounter with Michael Myers which
she says gives her nightmares in
Halloween 4 the return of Michael Myers
we also see Jaime having nightmares
about the boogeyman implying that at the
very least Laurie did teach her about
her family's history with evil despite
Karen's best efforts Lori's trauma still
trickles down to Allison Allison feels
hurt by Karen's always active attempts
to keep Lori away and keeps prodding to
find out if her mom has invited Lori to
her honors celebration dinner Karen lies
to her and states that she did ask but
Lori would not be able to make it
Allison is particularly hurt by this
because she knows her mother is lying
but Karen sees this as a way of
protecting her and we soon see why
Allison goes around Karen and invites
her grandmother anyway when Lori arrives
Karen's lie is revealed however the
issue is immediately puts a rest by
Lori's own erratic Behavior she shows up
drinking and ranting in a way that makes
her look insane Karen responds by
setting boundaries and offering
suggestions such as going for a walk or
hitting the reset button and starting
over that seemed like something one
might learn in therapy or even Implement
as a therapist
the Sheep mom
I think maybe this is a little bit too
much for you huh why don't we go for a
walk all right you said you were gonna
put the pass behind you okay are you
gonna try to do that that's what you
said you wanted to do you can't mom look
at me there is a specific reason that
Karen communicates this way in addition
to the therapy that we can safely assume
that Karen has gone through Karen may
actually be a therapist herself based on
the way she tells Allison that she
rescheduled her last session so that she
can attend Allison's induction into the
National Honor Society I mean she could
be a personal trainer or a prostitute I
guess but she just doesn't look the part
in the original script she's actually
described as a children's psychologist
it's not kind of in the movie but I'm
kind of willing to go with that it makes
sense that Karen would be inspired to
choose a profession where she could help
kids that were going through what she
went through however despite Karen
making it very clear how bad her
childhood was and obviously choosing not
to pursue a relationship with her mom
Lori does not regret how she chose to
raise Karen she still feels it necessary
to do what she considers protecting her
by breaking into her house to point out
the lacking security system it reminds
me of those guys on cop shows who get
caught stealing a car and then they try
to say that they were in the process of
returning it but like if they were
actually telling the truth Applejack
gonna take the car to the police station
once again Karen uses the tools she has
learned through therapy to navigate this
unwanted interaction with her mother
stating that Lori needs to get help and
that she's not welcome in this house
until she gets it also Rey makes a
feeble and embarrassing attempts to
defend Karen hey Lori this is my home
and I can take care of my own family all
right I know Jiu Jitsu Ray thinks he's
Buster Rhymes out here can't blame Lori
for not trusting Rey with anyone's
safety I can understand Karen's desire
to start a family that's going to be
different from her situation growing up
but really this guy it comes as no
surprise that Rey is not able to get
Lori to leave and it's Karen who has to
intervene insisting that the world is
not a dark and evil place it's 2018
Karen if only you stuck around a couple
years unfortunately for Karen all of
Lori's fears were about to come true and
in no amount of positive thinking or
Christmas sweaters would be able to
prevent the force that is Michael Myers
as news of his Escape spreads through
Haddonfield Lori and Deputy Hawkins are
the first to take it seriously and
spring into action Hawkins agrees that
Michael is likely after Lori and her
family and assists her in convincing
Karen to take shelter at Laurie's house
however Allison is not with Karen and
they can't reach her phone making it
impossible to track down Allison's
current whereabouts left with little
Choice Karen and Rey leave for Lori's
house leaving messages for Allison to
meet them there when they arrive Karen
is faced with reminders of all the past
trauma that she had tried so hard to
leave behind the Trap that they prepare
for Michael in the basement brings up
Twisted memories of Karen's nightmarish
experiences working down there as a girl
despite her feelings about how her
childhood transpired it's clear that her
training has made her an expert on using
a gun you never wanted to listen when I
spoke that night and this is why I
for a long time it doesn't take long for
Michael to find them and I'm sure no one
will be shocked to learn that Rey is the
first to be killed
Karen hides in the basement alone when
Michael breaks in and she hears her
mother's battle with the boogeyman rage
on all throughout the house above her
it's during the struggle that Allison
after having her own traumatic night
finds her way in as well Karen calls her
downstairs and they both hide in the
basement but Michael is able to find the
secret entrance and muscle the kitchen
island that's blocking it out of the way
with nothing standing between her and
her family's worst nightmare Karen begs
and pleads for Lori to find them crying
that she can't do it by herself and
Michael realizing he has a trapped
victim appears in the stairway but Karen
is only acting
gotcha
despite her attempts to put her
childhood combat training behind her
it's still ingrained in her memory like
remembering how to ride a bike or I
guess in her case instead of learning
how to ride a bike because she's the
180s kid that didn't do that seeing the
horror from Haddonfield firsthand causes
Karen to completely drop her world is
not a dark and evil Place attitude and
from that point forward she becomes just
as vicious as her mother Alison and
Karen adjusted barely escaped Michael's
grasp as they Rush up the stairs and
it's Karen who activates the bars and
locks Michael into the basement tomb
which is now filling up with guys Lori
throws in a flare which starts a huge
fire the entire house has been designed
as a track so that if this day should
ever come Michael would burn down with
it we see a dollhouse in Karen's old
room and go up in Flames which
represents Karen's childhood Karen
always wanted to be a normal kid but
lordy wanted to train her for combat the
image represents the trade-off Karen was
forced to make all of those years ago
she's giving up her normal childhood in
exchange for safety as an adult the
three generations of women were able to
flee the house and flag down a ride from
a couple of Illinois boys thinking that
they have successfully killed Michael
Myers and ended the terror that is hung
over their town for the last 40 years
however this hope would soon be
extinguished
[Music]
when Lori Allison and Karen get to the
hospital Lori has rushed into emergency
surgery leaving Karen and Allison to
cope with the loss of Rey Karen looks at
her blood-soaked hands and tries to wash
the Gory stains from her wedding ring
signifying that she'll never be able to
return to the optimistic life and
worldview that she had worked so hard to
build with her husband as Karen and
Allison are questioned by police they
both learn that Michael survived and
escaped Allison wants to join her
boyfriend and the town mob to go look
for Michael and kill him while Karen is
certain that he'll be coming to the
hospital and that they should stick
close to Lori and protect her she later
goes into her mom's room as she's waking
up and discovers a note left behind by
Allison explaining that she's joined the
anti-michel knob and that it is her love
for her family that is driving her to
hunt him down and not unlike Lori I can
only imagine how crushing this was for
her she spent her whole Parenthood
trying to give Allison a better life
only to see her become a fighter just
like her grandmother when it's most
critical for them to stick together
despite this she does a really
impressive job of keeping it together in
order to prevent Lori from finding out
that Michael survived she probably just
needed some fresh air the goal is to
keep Lori in bed so she continue to heal
and this is the second time Karen has
manipulated her emotions to trick
someone the first being when she acted
like a helpless victim at the foot of
the basement stairs she leaves her mom
alone to get some rest at which point
she runs into Tommy Doyle and only wants
to hear one thing from him but even
after finding out she still stays at the
hospital because she really seems to
believe that Michael is after Lori
whereas Allison believes that Michael
just wants to kill whatever is in his
path this divide could be explained by
the fact that Allison sees that Dr
Sartain was the one to bring Michael and
Laurie together and Karen doesn't know
about that she's been told all of her
life that Michael is going to come for
them and from her point of view hiding
in the basement that is exactly what
happened and to be fair if this were any
other Halloween movie she would have
been right she watches as Tommy Riles up
the mob and her reaction to me says they
have no idea what they're in for she
does her best to stop Tommy from barging
into Lori's room and revealing that
Michael Myers is still alive but he
spills the beans anyways Karen tries to
justify her Lie by saying it was for her
mom's safety which is honestly fair I
think it's one of the few Justified lies
just because it's a situation where
telling the truth would more than likely
put Lori directly In Harm's Way when she
needs to focus on healing it seems Karen
is always willing to bend the truth in
order to protect those closest to her as
we saw when she lied to Allison about
inviting her grandmother to dinner she
insists that despite what Lori May thank
all of her preparation was for nothing
yet Lori still firmly disagrees and
hilariously drugs herself up with
painkillers
what the hell did I just witness the two
basically get into a big fight which
culminates with this
gonna let anything thing happened to you
Karen has now unsuccessfully bagged both
her daughter and mother to stay with her
words safe which is another similarity
she shares with Jaime Lloyd in Halloween
5 Jaime has a vision of danger at the
Halloween party her friend Tina is going
to but nobody will take her seriously
and Tina goes to the party anyway it is
not too long after this that the angry
mob finds another escaped mental patient
named Mr tavoli and they mistake him for
Michael Myers Lori is the first to
realize that it's not Michael but she
gets injured in the Stampede so Karen
takes it upon herself to try to protect
the man but despite her best efforts
she's unable to save his life back in
the hospital room Hawkins informs Lori
and Karen about what I was talking about
earlier the fact that Dr Sartain was the
one to bring Michael to Laurie earlier
that evening this Revelation makes Karen
realize that if Michael isn't targeting
Lori then her daughter is in danger of
encountering him out on the streets of
Haddonfield she gets Tommy to lend her
his car and they devise a plan to lure
Michael out into another trap thanks to
Deputy Hawkins story she deduces that
he's probably headed back home which is
likely where Allison and the others will
be to try to haunt him
did you know that when he was a little
boy he used to stand in his sister's
bedroom and
stare out the window maybe he wouldn't
look it out
maybe he was looking in at his
reflection at himself she wastes no time
getting there Allison had been traveling
with her boyfriend Cameron and Cameron's
dad Lonnie Elam so when she saw Lonnie's
empty car outside the Meyer's house she
must have feared for the worst she
grabbed a pitchfork from the Halloween
decorations on the porch and lucky for
her it's a real Pitchfork and it's
[ __ ] massive she shows up just in the
nick of time as Michael is about to
attack Allison Karen pulls his mask off
just like Lori did when he attacked her
all of those years ago like mother like
daughter and just like he was four
decades earlier Michael is transfixed by
the mask when it is taken from him I
imagine that Karen knows this because
Lori taught her everything she knew
about Michael Myers based on her
experiences that night and made sure
that she didn't forget a thing so Karen
uses the mask to lure him outside
drawing his attention away from the
injured Allison this scene has got to be
the biggest Jamie Lloyd connection of
them all Jaime like Karen will do
anything to protect her kid in Halloween
the curse of Michael Myers Jaime gives
birth to a son and uses a similar tactic
to protect him from the boogeyman she
hides him in a cabinet and runs away
with a bundle of blankets thereby
tricking Michael into following her as
far away as possible before she finally
succumbs to him and Michael is
bamboozled upon finding the empty
blankets that's basically what Karen is
doing here luring Michael out away from
her vulnerable daughter it's also an
important character development moment
for her all night she's tried to protect
the innocent people around her such as
her husband Mr tavoli heck even the town
of Haddonfield itself but she hadn't
found any success in Saving anybody with
her daughter's life on the line she
wasn't gonna settle for being too little
or too late Michael gives Chase but
instead of sacrificing herself at the
end like Jaime did she leads him into a
trap where Tommy Doyle and the angry mob
are waiting the sheer numbers of the mob
are able to beat him down and before
going back with her daughter Karen gets
one good knife shot into Michael's upper
back she reunites with Allison and tries
to comfort her then as she gets up to
give the paramedics some space she looks
up at Michael's window and perhaps
remembering Frank Hawkins story she sees
a strange vision of the child Michael
Myers in his clown costume staring out
over Haddonfield this moment is another
that she shares with her original
timeline counterpart because in
Halloween 4 the return of Michael Myers
Jaime looks into a mirror and sees child
Michael staring back at her with the
same emotionless expression this is
reflective of Frank's earlier words
maybe he wasn't looking out maybe he was
looking in at his reflection at himself
Karen heads upstairs to see for herself
what Michael might have been looking at
but instead of seeing her own reflection
she sees Michael he appears behind her
and this time with no support network
around to help her he takes the knife
and finishes her off the very last
parallel she shares with Jamie Lloyd who
was also met with a grisly death at the
hands of haddonfield's most feared
resonance I've got more episodes lined
up for other 40-year timeline characters
so let me know who else you'd like to
see covered here on Horror history and
remember to subscribe to cz's world for
new Horrors every week ring that death
bell and make sure you select all
notifications please please and I will
see you in the next one assuming we both
survive
[Music]
foreign